the last time someone said Terry needs
no introduction they kept that they kept
on going and said so let me tell you
something about myself so I was in New
York a few days ago and I had lunch with
Jim Simons whose foundation is funding
this institute and and this workshop of
the program of the workshop and you
probably know that in addition to the
one here at Berkeley there's also one
apt of MIT math Institute and there's
something in New York City called a
flatiron Institute which now is really
big it's like a data Science Institute
but he was telling me that they have
like three big programs they want a
fourth in computational neuroscience wow
this is amazing
you know we've reached the point now
where a mature field and actually have
resources and opportunities so if
anybody here is interested in being the
next director please let me know because
he asked me if I had any good
suggestions and you know it's it's
actually up to you right with the future
of the field okay so
if we look back in the history of
neuroscience right the traditional way
that you record in the brain in fact
going back 100 years is from the scalp
and it was already known you know back
in in the in the days of Hans Berger
that the brain it has electrical
activity that is constantly changing and
that the patterns of activity are
related to your state of behavior if
you're resting and you close your eyes
there's a big alpha component 10 Hertz
and if you're actively making decisions
for example there's a activity in the
beta range which is lower in frequency
or higher actually 12 roughly 14 to 23
Hertz and then in the 60s it became
possible to work from single neurons and
that really changed the whole landscape
because it was possible to ask a
question of what does this specific
neuron respond to what the visual
stimulus does it respond what auditory
stimulus is respond to what motor
pattern is it correlated with in the
motor system right and if you ask if you
think about those questions those are
all having to representation how do the
neurons represent the world how they
represent the state of your motor system
right but as ELA pointed out the vast
majority of the brain is fall somewhere
between the early sensory processing and
the motor output it's it's really what
we used to call back in the early 80s
the hidden units right they're hidden
from their their activity is really not
specified a by just of the constraints
from the world but also by the intrinsic
activity within the cortex and this is
something that has been reported you
know going back to the very first
recordings it was noticed that they
called it spontaneous activity or
maintained activity it was
this bubbling background but it wasn't
just a constant bubbling it was dynamic
it was changing it was shifting it was
related to the behavioral state but in
some cryptic way that was impossible to
actually easily decode and illest Ock
shows us that there are no techniques
that allow us to get to those internal
latent hidden states now there's another
interesting point to be made which has
to do with the fact that we've pretty
much if you really look at trying to
understand the global patterns of
activity in the brain and yuji's one
example functional magnetic resonance
imaging another example right these
global states are really critically
important for integrating information
and now let's think about the brain okay
so just to calibrate the the biggest
deep Learning Network these days has a
few hundred million parameters in it
maybe a billion in one cubic millimeter
of cortex there's a billion synapses all
right so what really what we have is
something is there a tiny in comparison
to the computational capacity and Terra
cortex the entire cortex is hundreds of
thousands could be you know filled with
hundreds of thousands of the deep
learning networks and now the the
problem is you know how do you connect
them together how do you integrate all
that of representational power and and
therefore this isn't really the message
here which is that there has to be a
completely separate system within the
cortex and in fact within the entire
brain whose primary purpose is
communication right we'll just look at
we have all these desktop computers who
wasn't until the internet connected them
up that it became a powerful organized
system of transferring information right
so is the communication that really is
as important or maybe more important
than the actual computing that's going
on locally and how do we understand
how do we approach it what are the
questions and issues and and who's
studying it right
okay well we'll get back to that later
now let's go back to human weasel right
so we know that you know they they were
one of the first to actually analyze the
response properties of these neurons now
it's true it's true that if you record
the response of a neuron in the visual
cortex to its optimal stimulus you get a
bunch of spikes but if you repeat the
same stimulus twice you don't get the
same spike pattern
and as a consequence they always
reported the average that's called the
spoke post stimulus time histogram
Psch and you have to average over 10 or
more trials to get something that's
reproducible you know the cuz the actual
spike timing is variable in fact
sometimes this is really shocking
sometimes there's no responsible you
know what's going on here I thought the
brain was reliable here but I think the
computer wants to go to sleep okay okay
and I'm going to illustrate that now in
the recordings from Dan Feldman who's
here at Berkeley what he did here was to
stimulate one whisker in the a rats pad
of whiskers and and there's a mapping
from the whisker pad whisker by whisker
to the cortex they're called barrels in
the cortex and if you record from the
barrel of a whisker who's stimulated
you're stimulating and recording now
from a layer 5b cell in barrel cortex it
means a lower part of the oh the the
part of the cortex actually it projects
out the subcortical e so here's here's a
stimulus and you can see that the PS th
is very nice it gives you a burst here
and then there's another burst here but
wait a second let's look at individual
trials right you look at this trial
there were no spikes or sometimes just
one spike right we're not talking here
about it's something that can be
characterized by a firing rate for a
single try by the way the animal can
detect that that a slight movement of
the whisker you know very very
accurately so that means it can somehow
integrate over all the neurons but each
individual neuron as you can see and
this is now from different parts of the
of the of the the whole system of Baral
system so this is really a interesting
question as because
related to the spontaneous activity
question and it is related to an
observation first made by mirror and
grin vault who is one of the first to
get voltage sensitive dyes to work in
the cortex and this is in the visual
cortex and so you're looking down this
is a monkey and if you stimulate the
right eye or the left eye you get these
ocular dominance comp so this is below
with this is primary visual cortex v1
and you see above that it looks
different that's the v2 so there's a
border here so here's the experiment is
very simple
and and the color coding here is the
degree of activity as measured by a
voltage sensitive dye so this is
milliseconds after the stimulus stimulus
consists of a spot of white at a very
tiny spot of light and just looking at
you know what would be if you know when
you're looking down at the cortex and
you can see there's a delay here and
it's 48 milliseconds before you start
seeing something now the actual spot
itself on this vid this is about four
millimeters across so the actual spot
itself is about that probably about this
size if you just look at the neurons
that are directly connected to that spot
from the retina but you can see that it
grows and it grows and it grows over a
hundred two hundred milliseconds
spreading out now you get spikes in the
centre but you don't get any spikes in
the background and why is that and the
reason is that voltage sensitive dyes
are giving you information about
sub-threshold activity just in what's
happening is that these cells are
actually around it are being depolarized
maybe not to threshold and so this is
really evidence that there is a
traveling wave that starts out at the
point of the stimulus and spreads out
over many millimeters of the cortex we
even know the substrate there are
something called long-range horizontal
connections and and they tend to be
fairly slow and which may account for
the fact that it takes a 100
milliseconds or more for that
information to spread out okay so this
is was a mystery at the time I mean
people how do you interpret this and why
is it there because if all you see is
spikes the picture looks very different
but it clearly if information is coming
in at several
from places on the cortex at the same
time as it is in natural scenes then all
of these the cells here are going to be
getting sub threshold activation for
many different parts of the visual field
at different time delays right so that's
really what we wanted to explore yeah
this is okay this is that's right uh to
explain to you but there's a hole in the
skull of the monkey and you look a
camera is looking down and they put a
dye into the cortex which gets into the
membrane and reports there's small
changes in the the the amount of light
coming back what the membrane potential
is right and emit most of the membrane
potential is in the nerve pill has to
its synaptic activity membrane
potentials not spikes right so that's
what you have to know so it still is
this party what scale is this this is
about four millimeters across oh it's
this large area yeah this huge it's
actually very very large right it's it's
some covers you know several columns
here okay
now let's jump to the hippocampus so
here's the hippocampus spread out you
know sort of peeled back it's kind of
wound up like a French roll but the area
that I'm gonna be focusing on is ca one
which is the output from the hippocampus
and I want to focus here at the top
that's called the dorsal surface at the
top and and it's known that if you
record from one of these neurons in a
track where the rat or the mouse is
running along that there will be places
along the track where their neuron will
suddenly start firing and in the case of
dorsal hippocampus you know it'll be
centimeters to a meter in terms of the
spatial extent and and there are place
fields all the way along in different
parts of this dorsal hippocampus now as
you go down and this is only known very
recently because most people put their
electrode from the top and they stop
when they get here but if you go down
ventrally to the bottom it turns out
that place heels get bigger and bigger
bigger and to the point where they've
become so big that they cover you know
the whole
invite the entire little ring normally
they call the mazes and they're
typically about a meter or two around
and and it wasn't until people realize
that if you really want to understand
place feels and then with our call grid
cells you need to go down the hallway
like you know 1015 meters in order to be
able to see the regular patterns here of
place fields so this has been known for
a long time and this is goes back to
general Keith in the 60s and Nobel Prize
was given for this oh just a couple
years ago okay now in addition to these
place fields there's something else that
is very dramatic and extremely well
characterized that is going on
dynamically so when the rat is actually
exploring its environment there is a
regular frequency it's called the theta
of oscillation in the hippocampus and
it's four to ten Hertz and and you can
see this is actually in the slice and
this is actually now in vivo so it's not
as quite as nice in the slice just to
compare you know this is really an
isolation so this is a little bit more
ragged let me let me take you through it
so there if this is a depth electrode
that has sixteen different paths where
you can record activity and to hear
there according to local field potential
which is the sum of input of a lot of
local circuitry and at the very top
we're in cortex and the very middle here
we're in the hippocampus and the top
part the pyramidal cell layer in the
middle and then the bottom part of the
hippocampus and then it actually gets
down to another part of the hippocampus
called the dentate gyrus where the
inputs are coming in and and what I want
to show you is that first of all the the
the the not perfectly regular but the
actually quite repear eaat ik and
repeatable oscillation in that four to
eight Hertz range ask the theta
oscillation and passing I just want to
mention that if you look at the crest
here you'll see that there's also
another oscillation at a higher
frequency called the
gamma oscillation and that's a lot of
the order of 30 to 80 Hertz and so
there's nested isolations here it's not
like you know this one buzz it's like
you know there are several at the same
time and they're nested and and and you
know it this is the dentate look look at
how big the theta is there so the theta
is really extends across the whole
hippocampus and it's also found by the
way in the internal cortex that feeds
into the hippocampus so this is like a
very widespread organizing temporal
signal now again this has been known for
50 years and it's it's it's it's
enormous and it's very regular and it
goes on it's a real oscillation but
listen until Thanos Safi ops say AAPIs
who's at Caltech put an array of
electrodes across the hippocampus that
we actually saw the spatial organization
right so here it is this is the long
axis of the hippocampus and here's the
array and let's now look at the activity
pattern on the array during a time when
the animal is locomoting so red is when
it's at its peak and blue is when it's
at its nadir and I think it's pretty
clear that this is not an oscillation
it's a traveling wave right somebody
convinced this has been around for 10
years nobody knows what to make of it I
mean the people do the hippocampus no
it's really funny you talk them he said
oh yeah I remember that paper but
basically you ignore it why why don't
people ignore it they ignore it because
they can't fit it into anything it
doesn't make any sense right why should
a traveling wave be there right what's
it doing there okay well let's take us
seriously okay so I already showed you
this on the left but let's now look at
what this traveling wave means for these
different parts of the hippocampus right
so this is that longitudinal axis that
you saw and then in the array and what
it means is that the if you look at the
local field potential here it's going to
reach peak 70 milliseconds
before it reaches peak down here so
there's there's a temporal gradient and
by the way the cells actually fire the
you know it when there's a peak it's
actually at the minimum of the local
field potential but it's it's at the
peak where the membrane potential but
the point the point is though that
there's temporal offsets and this is
going to be really really important
because there's really the thing that's
been ignored universally almost in most
of the work that's been done in vision
and even in the hippocampus is time
delays time delays are ubiquitous I mean
their axonal time delays right so axons
are if they're really lousy wires right
that they transmit information on the
order of meters per second and they
compared to the speed of life that's
really lousy you know for your computer
right yeah literally you know you could
send signals back and forth near the
speed of light so you know is it is it
the case that nature is can't do any
better or maybe because it had these
slow axons that actually decided to take
advantage of them right well well let's
find out let's take a look at what they
could be used for so one of the
interesting the the issues has to do
with when is it that you change the
strength of a synapse and it turns out
that here our timing is really important
so this is a classic experiment was done
in the hippocampus by booming Pugh and
it represents this is in a slice where
you were recording simultaneously from
two neurons and you're able to stimulate
both of them at different time points
right relative to each other and here
focus up here this is when okhla here on
the right when the presynaptic input is
activated through neuron a and you can
see that the postsynaptic cell membrane
potential is increasing because that's
the synaptic input and then after a
slight time delay which is along this
axis you stimulate the postsynaptic cell
right with an action potential and you
pair that at some frequency
and it and you come back you compare the
strength of that synapse before and
after the pairing and if it's within a
20 millisecond window you can double the
strength
that's called long-term potentiation but
if you reverse the order now you do post
before a pre so here's that that a
synaptic potential within a 20-minute
window you can decrease the strength
that's long-term depression so they're
they're like really exceptional
precision here because we're talking
about difference between depression and
potentiation in the middle of second
range you may this is this is really
high precision and this is really
incredibly important it makes a big
difference whether you're going to
increase or decrease right so that's one
thing that's important the other thing
is that if you pair this at less than 10
Hertz like five Hertz you don't get this
it has to be ten Hertz or higher
okay well that's interesting too because
it means that there's several necessary
steps here precise timing and number two
high enough frequency frequency of
pairing where you stimulate pre and post
with with that time delay you know okay
I'm we're gonna come back to this now
because this is gonna turn out all these
little pieces I've been giving you are
like little breadcrumbs that are out in
the literature I mean literally hundreds
of papers all over the place that are
giving us some hints but unfortunately
they're very difficult to put together
it's like a puzzle right you have a
jigsaw puzzle and you take a couple
pieces out and you begin to see the
relationships maybe the colors are
similar here and maybe the the shapes
are similar here but somehow from all of
as you can see more pieces the puzzle
you begin you know the picture seems to
come out but you know we're at the bare
still at the stage where we have lots of
pieces but not a lot of patches yet put
together and I'm gonna try to put
together one of these patches for you
now sleep has been already mentioned a
couple of times and and and it's it's
one of the most remarkable behaviors
that we do every day every single one of
us
I shouldn't actually presume how many
people here went to sleep plus they put
up your hand
okay somebody there how many people wish
they went well that's the point is that
if you don't get you're asleep then you
have to pay the price right sleep
deprivation and and so that's it's
literally a third of your life time
you're you're knocked out and why and
and we actually have many many theories
and almost no experimental evidence that
really pins it down and it's very likely
it's not for just one thing there are
many many things that are going on in
your brain but one thing that's really
we know for sure is that it's not that
your brain turns off right you think
that if you're conserving energy well
why not just turn it off right that
would be the sensible thing to do no no
it actually is almost as active visit us
during the day but the patterns of
activity have changed dramatically and
in particular you get in during the
night very low frequency waves that are
oscillations that are not connected to
anything in the world completely
intrinsically generated and and it
changes during the night so when you
fall asleep you go through a sequence of
stages until you get to slow-wave sleep
which is three four down here and that's
when you have this lowest frequencies
two to four Hertz very highly amplitude
and spatially and temporally coherent
and that's what's really neat because it
means that there's a global state there
it's not just processing information
locally in different parts for different
purposes different sensory inputs and so
forth it's the whole cortex suddenly is
somehow then stitched together and now
during the night you periodically go
between slow-wave sleep and rapid eye
movement sleep would you heard about
dream sleep and back and forth back and
forth spending less and less time and
slow-wave more and more time in rapid
eye movement sleep until finally you
wake up at the end of eight hours now
and hear a representative EEG recording
since then you can see that the
amplitude for awake and REM which is
down here are very small they're very
similar in fact the textbook says you
can't discriminate
them but in fact with machinery you can
it's not we have but but compare that to
the slow way see look at these huge to
four Hertz delta waves now the the stage
that I want to focus on is this
intermediate stage too
and in fact most people spend about half
of their time in stage two because you
have to go between REM and slow way if
you always stop at Stage two and what's
going on in stage two in fact it's very
easy to identify because that's when
sleep spindles occur sleep spindles
occur thousands of times during the
night they last one or two seconds
they're on the order of ten Hertz the
same band as the Alpha BAM
and they consists of bursting and we
note that they're generated in the
thalamus the thalamus is the relay
station that takes input from a sensory
out from the sensory periphery into the
thalamus and then through their relays
it up to the cortex and in addition to
the feed-forward there's also
connections from the cortex layer six
which is the bottom of the cortex down
to the thalamus so there's actually a
loop between the cortex and the thalamus
and we now know that four spindles and
I've spent 20 years studying this with
Mir chest area david mccormick we have
very detailed biophysical models down to
the ion channels and we I can tell you
in exquisite detail how they get started
how this the thalamus recruits the
cortex and through the feedback
connections become spatially coherent
right that's one of the ways that the
thalamus is able to organize the cortex
okay so that's that's what we've been
studying and typically studied
here studied in the cab this is by
inertia stereo by putting a bunch of
electrodes inside the thalamus and then
the only two here in the cortex but at a
distant location and here's the
recording over about a minute and you
can see that they recur every five or
ten seconds and here's two spindles that
are blown up and it's pretty convincing
that you know they really do are both
you know widespread and also it starts a
little bit first in the thalamus but
then recruits the cortex and with the
existing techniques that they had it
looked like they are pretty much
synchronous and this was something a
David and Mary and I often debated you
know what do you mean by synchronous do
you mean that it's within you know it's
a 10 100 millisecond period so is it ok
to be within 10 milliseconds of each
other five 20 what what's the definition
of synchronous at this point if you're
talking about the whole cortex right and
in in in in some ways part of the
problem was that people never put more
than one or two in the cortex at the
same time you know you do it properly
you'd have to have a whole rake to Texas
be able to make measurements across the
whole cortex ok well now let's think
about the one possible function for
which there's actually increasing
evidence which is that we know that for
many many psychological experiments that
if you do some learning and then take a
nap and come back you're able to do the
task better whether it's uh remembering
things that you've associated or even
the perceptual learning being able to
detect weak stimuli or a motor learning
right so it's it's thought from
psychologists that there must be
something going on in your brain during
sleep which helps you consolidate that
experience that you just had and and we
actually now have a theory based on work
that recording some rats that actually
buttresses that theory and so here's how
the theory goes this is coming from
you're a jockey who's winning one of the
leaders in recording
from the neurons different parts of the
hippocampus and the cortex so here's the
idea that when the rat is out there
exploring the world
different areas of the hippocampus at
the top of a big hierarchy all the
sensory hierarchies end in the
hippocampus and so it's really a
convergence zone for you know your
entire sensorial but each of these
modules from the different sensory
systems that projects broadly into the
hippocampus will activate those
hippocampal neurons during the theta
when the animal is exploring and it's
known that there this is a time when
there's potentiation occurring in the
hippocampus so some trace of that
experience has actually been embedded
into the hippocampus yeah you fall
asleep you go through the sequence of
events I've already described and in
particular it's known and you'll
actually mention this that but what
happens is that the cortex goes into the
slow wave mode the slow waves hipa kata
like mo but now even lower frequency and
now the hippocampus is talking back to
the cortex and and it does it with these
sharp waves these are very brief bursts
of high-frequency activity in some some
in some cases hundreds of Hertz and and
and this then triggers sleep spindles so
this is how the sleep spindle is is is
initiated and that can go on in
slow-wave sleep for an hour hour and a
half at the beginning of the night but
then it switches it switches when the
cortex suddenly wakes up it gets into
this REM state and the REM now starts
talking back to the hippocampus and it
cycles back and forth the idea is that
constantly what's happening is that the
information is flowing from the
hippocampus that was a recent experience
into the cortex and with the problem
that you have in the cortex is to
integrate information that might be
stored in different parts of the cortex
for example suppose that I met somebody
for the first time and I think they
don't think we've never met before but
this very place to meet you and so I
have a visual impression of you I know
how you talk and you have a nice warm
hand right somatosensory auditory visual
that's a different parts
the cortex and I also know your name
because it's written on your chest which
is in the military so here's the problem
ok the next day someone asks you know
did you see been you and I said oh wait
second yeah I'm pretty sure she was on
the program and I have to remember what
your face looks like and have to
remember you know all the things that
have happened right that's an event that
occurred and I want to be able to
remember a you know long term and so how
would all those neurons connect it so I
can do recall so how I can take what
little pieces of information and
complete the pattern in different parts
of the cortex so the idea is that
somehow we need to create connections
between long-distance connections
between those neurons and that is why
you have to do this and you want to do
it in a way that minimally minimally
disturbs the existing information
otherwise if I if I do it wrong right
there maybe somebody else is named that
this gotten blocked there was a funny
story that Jeff Fenton once told me his
father was an entomologist who studied
beetles and he said Jeff's father
refused to remember the names of any of
the students because it for every
student's name that he remembered he
forgot the name of a beetle well it's
all about priorities right okay but
here's the theory the theory is that
after enough cycles and by the way this
isn't just it turns out that you need to
have the hippocampus around for weeks
and months because you're always you're
always going back and forth for people
who have lesions of the hippocampus and
the region around it they can't store
new memories in other words they have an
experience one day they come back the
next day and they have no memory they
can be introduced to you and and so
forth but they have no conscious recall
the fact that that they saw you
yesterday there's some funny anecdotes
along those lines that you know if you
tell them a bad joke they'll laugh at it
and you come back the next day and
they'll laugh at it in exactly the same
way than they were say old jokes don't
get old if you have amnesia okay it's
clearly and this computer's has amnesia
problems here okay so the idea though is
after enough of these psych
after enough days and weeks and so forth
at the end you start that you've created
connections between the neurons and the
different modules and now you can get
doubt you know you restored the capacity
because the hippocampus is actually very
small compared to the capacity of the
cortex so this is only a temporary it's
not even a setting the storing
information it's actually storing the
links and the cortex that have to be
recovered so it's a it's a very interest
more like hash code if you want to use a
computer science ontology okay so let's
now now give you I'm gonna give you one
experiment which to convince you that
these sleep channels actually might be
important for memory consolidation and
this was an experiment done by Sara
Mednick
and with what she does is on the first
day she gives a subject of placebo and
then they memorize a bunch of paired
associates just two random words of a
bunch of them and and you go and they
slit you go to sleep and and you measure
the number of sleep spindles the density
and then when they wake up you test to
see how many you remember so here we are
they could remember it's between three
and four now the next night what you do
is you instead of giving up Lucy bow or
you can actually you know balance it you
give them so padam which is ambien it's
a sleeping pill interestingly and it's
known that zolpidem actually increases
the density of sleep spindles so doubles
the sleep spindles and you come back in
the next morning and you test how many
that had they remember and lo and behold
it so it's almost three times twice as
high right so this is interesting means
that this drug you know which is an
intervention you're manipulating the
system and you're manipulating the the
spindles really did help with
remembering now those of you who have
used ambien should be a little skeptical
right now because people who take it
typically you know they are going on an
airplane they take it so they can sleep
on the airplane often they end up in
their hotel room not remembering how
they got there has anybody experienced
this and their travels
no nobody uses ambien okay okay it's
called hypnotic okay and so that this is
this has been shown you know this is a
real effect and but here's the
difference the difference is that it's
important here is that you do the
learning first and then you take the
ambien and it strengthens the memory but
if you take the ambien and then do
something you can't remember it right so
it's it's it's juggling you know we
peter has to pay Paul right you know you
you you're boosting memory of recent
past but at the expense of the near
future it's a very interesting drug okay
so now comes the the reveal this is
really the centerpiece of the talk and
it's something after twenty years of
research I could have never expected
from the animal literature and this is a
collaboration with sid cash at MGH who
works at epilepsy patients who come in
with drug-resistant epilepsy and the
last chance they have for getting rid of
it is to find out where in the cortex
it's starting right they focus and and
and take it out without taking out
anything it's important like the motor
system or the language system right
that's but that's the hope and it turns
out the temporal lobe is a hot spot
where a lot of epilepsy
starts including the hippocampus by the
way okay so here's a as it was done by
Lyle Muller and I just have to say at
the onset that the traditional
techniques that are used to analyze
these data is basically to average over
many cycles of the spindle because the
signals are very weak and when you do
that everything gonna tell you washes
out you have to look at single
oscillations
single cycles of the oscillation single
trials in a sense of what is the dynamic
pattern in the cortex we've normalized
the data these are an array of 64
electrodes on the surface of the cortex
called electro coreography acog
and each one of them has a is recording
the electrical field and we've
normalized it between 0 and 1 and then
great leveled it so that white
represents the peak and -1 represents
the trough across the whole array and
and so if you just focus on the one with
the red dot here's the actual
oscillation okay and I'm gonna play for
you in our movie and I'm gonna ask you
to if you see any pattern in the in the
movie that is reminiscent something that
you've seen in the movies so just follow
the the peak here this is one around
so that's about five cycles 100
milliseconds per cycle
dippy see what I saw we went from the
temporal lobe to the parietal lobe
so the prefrontal lobe what does that
remind you of Princess Leia okay it's a
traveling wave I would have never been
told me this I would say the hassle what
play it again play it again Sam okay
yeah so this is it's a brief clip no
it's a 100 milliseconds per cycle so
this is really slowed down here's time
and it's sort of like what you saw in
the different campus except yeah it's
linear it's a linear traveling wave so
okay so here's the bottom line if you
could not go back into literature so I
started digging back and one of my
colleagues at UCSD David Klein fills a
pipe physicists publish a paper 1990 on
traveling waves in the turtle cortex
completely you know obscure paper that
nobody has ever cited who's interested
in a turtle and second of all you know a
traveling wave you know maybe that's
just an artifact right I mean what is it
what does that mean ooh at me what
significance does it have and it turns
out that if you go back in literature
everything that was once called an
oscillation turns out really to be a
traveling wave gamma waves for example
grab gamma oscillations that have been
very popular among some people and been
ignored by others saying that this is
again it's just epic phenomenon that's a
traveling wave I'm going to show you a
couple more examples I mean this is it's
ubiquitous every single oscillation
sea-ice the concept of isolated the word
oscillation sort of implies a synchrony
right and and and that's when you have a
traveling wave that you're spreading the
information out over space it's not all
concentrated at the same time and and
you'll see computationally that gives it
it's much more powerful than having a
simple oscillation we'll get to that
okay now if you do by the way the amount
the analytic technique that while used
was taken from physics from fluid
dynamics where they had to find the
flows and and and and when you apply
that to this data set this is a single
cycle and the arrow points in degree of
increasing phase so this is a method
that depends on analyzing phase not the
peak and you need to do that because
again they're weak noisy signals but but
in fact you can reproduce I mean you can
really look at the global pattern of all
the cycles you know there's like 5,000
10,000 cycles during the night
about half of them are circular like
this about 70% are counterclockwise and
the other 30% are counterclockwise some
of them are expanding some of I mean
it's really it's a much more complex
pattern but we analyze it because we
really wanted to understand something
having to do with this idea of memory
consolidation so if if they have some
memory consolidation maybe they have
something to do with spike time
dependent plasticity right because
that's what mechanism we know exists in
the cortex and it depends on spike
timing okay
well let's imagine that there were
synchronous activity over the entire
cortex so that neurons were bursting
here at the same point in the cycle as
they were here so here are the two local
field potentials and here are the bursts
at a and B well the problem is that
their time delays long time delays
across the cortex and the white matter
these are the tracks that connect the
different parts of the cortex and say
that there's a 20 millisecond delay
between a and B well that means that
after the bursts in a the the synaptic
inputs occur in B 20 milliseconds later
and this is post before pre remember
post before pretty repeated paired at 10
Hertz is going to give you Ltd right the
10 Hertz was important right if if the
spindles are 5 Hertz then it wouldn't
there be no synaptic plasticity at all
with this mechanism and if you have Ltd
that means that all the connection lug
DISA's connections will be disconnected
and that's of course not what you want
what you want is for the arrival of the
of the input from a to occur at the same
time is the peak and that means there
has to be a difference in when they're
bursting and so if you have a traveling
wave where there's a phase difference
between a and B a will burst 20
millisecond time delay and now you get a
burst in B at about the same time which
means you're in that millisecond plus or
minus 20 range so you can increase the
strengths of some synapses and decrease
others so this is compatible right it's
we don't have any proof but it just says
that this could be something of why you
might want time delays to actually occur
and travelling ways
now another interesting thing has to do
with how often the same pattern is
repeated and that varies with the
pattern but if - if you get two of those
phase diagrams I showed you that are
highly correlated between 0 & 1 but if
you have ones that are point point nine
or above then the very same pattern
recurs over the night hundreds of times
but if the correlation is below about
0.6 then it's it's a here's the the
shuffle control it's basically not
significant but a significant fraction
as you can see a few of them are picked
up and repeat it over and over and over
again suggesting that these are the
important ones these the ones that you
do want to remember and you're gonna
really get take every opportunity you
can to make sure that they get embedded
driven into the synapses that's good but
is it it's precise enough I mean how
much jitter is there for one of these
repetitions and the next I mean I said
that they're highly correlated but you
know it's really depends on the how the
relative timing of the cycle over and
over again and so here's the similarity
threshold that we have in the last slide
and as you can see the these are the
envelopes of the reproducibility from
from trial to trial from cycle to cycle
and it increases the the spread mid
spread is at the 5 millisecond level for
the most highly correlated patterns and
of course that's well within the plus or
minus 20 millisecond range so we're
talking here about the incredible amount
of precision I mean you know this is
amazing the cortex is huge and you know
why did they go out of its way to create
something that is so reproducible over
such a large part of the cortex with a
millisecond precision unless it was
taking advantage of that and SCDP of
course is exactly matching in terms of
what's needed
how many spikes are there in one of
these bursts only about on the order of
two to three three so you have spike
timing-dependent plasticity with with
multiple with triples
so it's very high frequency it's on the
order of let's say 100 200 Hertz yeah at
the you know a burst it's really it's a
low threshold calcium spike that which
has sodium spikes riding on top of it
okay well we want it you know so of
course you'd like to know can you model
this right and we wanted to know just
roughly looking in the literature what
have people done so what what's been
very common in literature is to take a
network model with local connectivity
because that's how we think the cortex
is organized with some inhibitory
neurons and lo and behold it's not
difficult to get a traveling wave that's
what surprising because you know you can
get recruitment and and these are what
we call dense travelling waves because
in the simulations all the neurons are
going to fire in sequence rate as and
the waves they have they can be a linear
waves or they could be circular waves it
depends on the initial conditions and
swirling patterns that's not a good
model for this because first of all
these waves traveling waves only
activate a very small a very sparse
number of parameter cells in the cortex
on every cycle not always the same
neuron on the same cycle they're very
very sparse they're not dense traveling
ways that our dance occurred during
epilepsy when you have massive you know
you know the activity has a heat is a
tremendous of firestorm of activity and
it spreads slowly or spreading
depression and these are extremely slow
compared to these in fact it's been
measured the time blades have been
measured and it turns out that the time
delays of these long-range connections
that they about 3 meter per second are
precisely in the range I was telling you
about to be able to support this
traveling wave and so we wanted to know
if you just took a bunch of coupled
oscillators this goes back to coromoto a
Japanese applied mathematician is
applied to getting explaining how it is
that fireflies become synchronized in a
tree for example and it turns out that
if you have a
two coupled oscillators that are coupled
by phase differences so that there's a
phase difference that one of them speeds
up and one slows down then they'll all
within a few cycles become synchronous
and this is also true of two old clocks
that have pendulums if you put them on a
shelf they synchronize because of the
weak vibrations in the shelf it's really
it's really a beautiful model it turns
out in the entire literature
nobody has ever put time delays in the
Cremona model right what would happen if
you put time delays in the chromite we
did that so here it is this is equation
for an oscillator a couple I said we put
them into an array we couple them
through their phase difference and now
this is where we put this something
different we put in time delays
according to the distance between the
locations in the cortex and to end
between the thalamus and the cortex it
turns out that there are different time
delays there as well so here's the
layout that it's our 8 by 8 connectivity
within the cortex and the thalamus and
here is the projection there's a there's
this is now a single neuron from the
cortex projecting back to the thalamus
and similar beam going up which is a
little bit more tight and now I'm going
to play the simulation so you can see
what that looks like it's of course a
very it's kind of a crude model it's not
at all realistic but I think it'll give
you an idea
it takes a couple cycles before it
settles down but when it does
right so it's a crude traveling circular
traveling wave
however the conative is based on the
human connectome between these different
areas we know with the concocted between
the primal cortex and the temporal
cortex and the prefrontal cortex we just
put that in I mean this is you know the
only there's only one parameter in the
whole model and that's the coupling
strength you know for the feedback and
depending on what that value was we
could tune it so that it does 70% of the
time in this direction and 30% of that
correction so so pixel here is an area
pixel here is a like the electrode on
the surface of the cortex now this is
just in one hemisphere and often people
will ask well what about the other
hemisphere right what's going on there
it was is it doing this or is it doing
hard to do things and and so we couldn't
do it because they only put in one array
they know what's on the right side they
put the array on the right side and it's
a very invasive operation by the way
it's really it's really horrible to have
that happen to you yeah but they
wouldn't be at the same rate or
frequency in other words I have put it
this way I think that the time delays
give you an intrinsic rate in which you
can propagate a sparse pattern of
activity if the key thing is the sparse
pattern if you if you only have a sparse
pattern in a local locally connected it
will die out they won't go very far
right because there's not enough
excitatory input coming in to keep the
wavefront going yo so you say that the
only a few neurons in the given
participating in these ways so anything
known about the laminar distribution of
the cells are active versus V&F yeah
yeah okay so well first of all the final
quarter pools go to layer 4 as you know
and then from there 2 to 3 and then from
there to other parts of the cortex
interestingly in the human we've
discovered that there's another pathway
called the inter laminar pathway again
you know about this that projects layer
1 and it turns out that if he put a
depth electrode into the cortex you can
show that there's actually two different
spindle systems there's one in layer 4
and there's one in layer 1 that involves
layer 1 and layer 5 so so these so the
answer is that it's ok and now okay
let's let's think about this from the
perspective of the EEG right why did
people see this as kind of coherent in
the EEG was because all these cortical
areas right the pyramidal cells are
projecting up in terms of their activity
patterns and if you just have a small
fraction that are coherent they're
firing you know spiking bursting at the
same time them they're going to show up
right because the you don't need that
many the rest of marker to cancel out if
they're firing at the same time or you
know randomly they will their
contributions will be the smaller but
but the the the the issue actually has
to do with whether a EEG is reflecting
what's happening in layer 1 or deeper
and my guess is is probably layer 1 is
the difference ok so that we think the
core is the layer 4 and the matrix is
layer 1 and that layer 1 is much more
diffused as the axons come up for the
inter laminar and they spread many
millimeters and so to do the dendrites
of layer 5 pyramidal cells so what's
going out there's much more diffuse
compared to the focal layer core which
goes to layer 4 ok but you know what's
it at the end of the day or the night at
the end of the night no when you wake up
what's what's going on we think that in
addition to having strengthen the
connections within each module
you've also have strengthened the
long-distance connections between the
modules so that means now that when you
have a visual input that can excite the
subsets of cells in the auditory system
or the language system which then can
the name of the person and the
experience you've had right even though
there are distance parts of cortex
that's that's our theory okay now I
already told you now that these are
epilepsy patients and and and if there
is a concern that maybe their cortex is
not normal they've had a place for years
and years and years they take into a lot
of drugs you know there's a concern that
in fact their cortex has reorganize
itself and maybe this is actually a part
of their that problem there may be the
epilepsy is really taken over the
connectivity in the cortex right so who
knows what's going on and so I was at a
meeting that was sponsored by the Kavli
Institute for brain and mind at UCSD and
April Bennett who studies babies she's
at the Rutgers University in Newark was
giving a talk and I was giving a talk
and at the end of the meeting the comple
Institute said look if any good ideas
have come out of this meeting we'd be
happy to fund them when's the last time
that's happened to you right and it
turned out that April I were just
talking about Hill you have you
collecting baby EEG
she studies babies that are six months
and 18 month old during the period when
they're developing language and the idea
is to try to find some markers that
would help predict whether the baby
would have language a disability or a
delayed language or delayed learning
okay they're they're tightly connected
and and so she's been collecting it and
she actually found some biomarkers which
are really quite interesting it's a
reduced maturity or the the delayed
maturity of the gamma processing signal
in the cortex which has to do with
higher attentional brain functions okay
but the babies sleep a lot they sleep
half the time in fact the the amazing
construction going on in the first year
of life the baby is like a sponge is
just being absorbing all the sensory
information and the figuring out how its
arm works it puts things in its mouth
wants to understand the world right and
and that's got to get integrated into
the synapses so it turns out there's a
tremendous burst of synaptogenesis
during that first year reaches a peak
than this pruning and then a very slow
decline right so there's a process here
of constructing the brain and it's maybe
not a surprise that they spend half
their time sleeping because if memory
consolidation is important then that's a
lot of they do a lot of spindling so we
collaborated with April she gave us some
of her data and I'm gonna show you this
is I showed it for the first time in New
York a few days ago and I so amazed when
I watch this this is looking down now
there's about a hundred electrodes here
both hemispheres this is the frontal
brain this is the back of the brain
right left you said it's not the not the
Ananda infrared this is this is EEG oh
by the way you know something you
probably know if you've had a baby which
is that they have very thin skulls it's
soft that's because their brains are
still expanding the sutures haven't
closed yet and the recording that
actually I was amazed I just didn't know
this the EEG the strength is as big as
the e [ __ ] it's as if you know you're
practically sitting on top the cortex
it's really amazing you know that you
can get these high quality EEG
recordings from babies that's not you
basic what no no no no the baby doesn't
have doesn't complain in fact the baby's
quite happy sleeping I don't believe
there it's really funny they I should
get picture of it they have this kind of
Judaic dome of electrodes over them so
they're they look like they're kind of
snowmen or something okay
look at that I mean it's amazing it's a
track it's a very structured highly
organized traveling wave across the
hemispheres and you know the hemisphere
it's the only connection is through the
close-up so this is really has to be
orchestrated in a really important way
this is looking down this is looking
down so yeah so so they're real-time no
no it's a hundred milliseconds roughly
from a once world this is the front this
is the back looking down is there some
consistent rate at which it reverses you
know this is so new we haven't had a
chance to look at this with the patterns
that you're seeing are really you know
they're we haven't done the phase
diagrams yet but I think it's pretty
clear that there's you're saying many
many cycles here so it has something
partner
we have about 10 babies well in in terms
of humans we had about eight humans but
we have like hundreds of thousands this
is one baby you're seeing right now
we're about five no no you're seeing
four only like one second is you saw
probably about ten or maybe 20 cycles
from one spindle okay so I have one more
here which is from the side now is there
going to rotate so you can see a
different aspect no no there you're
seeing actual song it's really important
I have to emphasize this you have that
everything look if you have this
swirling thing and you average over 20
cycles what are you gonna see you're
gonna see whether you've never see
nothing you just you just see a constant
right right so you have to look at this
cycle by cycle yeah it's very
interesting that you've shown us two
datasets with very different scales and
then your swirl happens right in the
middle of what you've looked at so I'm
wondering what wouldn't happen have no
matter what scale I looked at the others
in your model you've two time constants
one's about twice the other is that
it's gonna get you this type of swirling
behavior or okay so yeah we've been
doing a lot of modeling and I think the
critical number or the [ __ ] the critical
parameter it turns out to be the axial
velocity the speed which axons propagate
information one cortical area to the
next
and actually it's going to be a little
bit different in babies then because
their their brain is smaller so those
are a lot of interesting issues so let
me just play this this other a second
movie for you I just don't see how it
can be continuous across the midline but
is the midline does that so continue you
know why suit you mean the points that
they're connected at the midline right
somehow the waves seem to be continuous
across the midline although there's no
continuity and brain space across the
midline that's that there you go so what
somehow the connectivity must be created
such that it ends up integrating across
the cortex is there any myelination at
these events
well the oh yeah the long-distance
connections in the cortex oh they're
called white matter because they have a
lot of Milo makes it different parts of
the court yes interesting there's a wave
of myelination that occurs from the back
to the front but but it's also regulated
myelin is regulated in the sense that it
will in its known for an inferior olive
for example we're timing in a cerebellum
is really important that it during
development it's it's tuned so that you
have the right time delays millisecond
time delays in the cortex there's recent
evidence that when you're doing motor
learning that the actually the volume of
the cortex changes and it's the white
matter changes and it's thought that
that is might be due to more myelination
current but you know these are all
things that have to be looked at
carefully
you know because also if you think
this data in try to do source
localization you know is there another
explanation which is actually not a
traveling wave on the surface of the
entire context but some sources within
the brain that could create that ok so
they actually that's that's another good
suggestion that might help clay because
the thalamus is really the generator and
so it's the one that is doing the the
projections of the feedback from the
cortex of the thalamus of course creates
the spatial coherence but we don't have
our recordings from the thalamus to try
to understand what what the waves look
like down there they've got to be there
if you see it on the cortex well you
know but they're court ok this is
another interesting thing that Mara did
ok he did this experiment where you know
the question was is the spatial
coherence coming from connections within
the cortex are coming from connections
within the thalamus the reticular
nucleus of the thalamus covers the
entire thalamus and it's the feedback
it's the reciprocal inhibitory feedback
from within the relay cells to the
reticular nucleus that Crick causes the
spindle but but but there but it turns
out that if you put us knife cut through
the cortex and you are looking at two
parts of the thalamus the two parts of
the cortex become synchronized as they
that at least they thought they were
synchronized through the thalamic input
so it's the cortex going on autonomous
thalamus synchronizing within the
thalamus and then going back to the
cortex way to go across the midline
because when you first look at it you
think it's the corpus callosum doing
this but if it has to go down for Thomas
there's no route to do that freeze
well it might be a combination of you
know the the the thalamus well you
couldn't say the same thing how is it
that the thalamus
if the thalamus doesn't have any way to
communicate how is it that the cortex
the right and left hemisphere of the
cortex get synchronized which is what
everybody's always thought right I I'm
just I don't know the answer but I'm
thinking there's got to be some answer
to it right okay so this is I really
think that this is you know unearthing
some new principles and the question is
what computational value do they have
does there any effect on behavior other
than what's happening during sleep and
so we teamed up with John Reynolds a
colleague at the Salk Institute who
studies marmoset sue they have a flat
cortex and there's a part of the cortex
in the middle here called MT or v5 which
has cells that are directionally
selective so they're very specialized
with for things that are moving in the
world and we we had it turns out that
the size of that MT is just enough to be
covered by a Utah ray that has a 10 by
10 100 prongs that allows you to record
across the entire visual field and in
the MT at the same time and and here's
the experiment that we did and we were
asking a question of whether the waves
if their first is are there waves in Mt
in the wake behaving monkeys number 2 do
they have any impact on behavior so the
tasks that we have them do was to fixate
and then there was a after delay a a low
contrast moving de Bourg so this is like
stripes that are moving across the
visual field and their task was to
detect it and move their eye to it and
as you vary the contrast their hit rate
varies and this is the fraction of times
they're correct you can see if it's high
contrast above three and a half percent
which is actually pretty low they're
almost perfect and so we said it at 50
percent so that they're there they're
getting it right half the time and so
there's they're making a lot of misses
okay here's a raster plot of recording
from one of those electrodes at the same
time that we're showing you the
local field potential and you can see
that at this point the stimulus comes
and there's a very a burst of firing
which occurs in this case before high
contrast stimulus that can be easily
detected in the spike firing so now you
take it down to 50% and then you look at
how well the animal was able to detect
the target as a function of the oops I
guess I didn't even show you this in my
speed to get here okay this is
recordings from the array
just like in the case of the spindles
from the visual cortex you can see that
the waves are traveling across in this
case it's right ten verse there's
actually two waves there's a distant
Hertz wave and there's also a much lower
frequency two to four Hertz raised which
is spontaneous there I showed you at the
beginning there's whenever you put up a
spot there's a stimulus evoked wave that
propagates when you make us a CAD
there's a stimulus others say now it's a
CAD evoked wave that starts and this was
a stimulus evoke wave the ten Hertz and
when you look at the phase of the wave
when is it wouldn't win to get more hits
it turns out that it's at one phase when
the cells are depolarized when the wave
is going through and the lfp is actually
at a minimum and the membrane potential
is it a maximum not too surprising
because that's when you're closer to
threshold so a weak stimulus will more
likely produce spikes and indeed that's
what happens if you look at the spikes
and the neurons they occur in that phase
when it's more depolarize and if you do
a phase locking analysis for the hits
and the misses there's a very highly
significant signal here we're talking
about you know 0.001 so these waves have
a huge impact on behavior right they're
really this they're there and under
these conditions we we see that you
could detect the behavioral significance
but now and I want to tell you about a
paper that came out in fission of
letters just just a couple a year and a
half ago which I think raises some
interesting questions that actually
could be relevant this is these are
physicists who wanted to know something
about how the path this is a silicon
drop hitting an oil bath and then
bouncing as you can see it bounced
across the surface of the oil producing
ripples that then spread out but every
time it bounced and they asked the
following question if if at the end of
the bouncing right here we could take a
snapshot of the whole pattern
can we recover the trajectory of the
inputs the pattern of inputs and it
turns out that yes the whole history can
be reproduced it's like a holograph or
something right but it's a temporal it's
a sequence in time has been transformed
into a spatial pattern write the history
over the last you know with it maybe it
took a second to do that bang bang bang
bang right so a whole second of history
can be recovered and they even went
further and they introduced a shift that
allowed it to bounce all the way back
showing that you know there's enough
information so that you can reverse it
but now let's apply to the visual system
right v1 now the traditional view of how
information is propagated in the
hierarchy is that you know you flash a
stimulus it gets processed in v1 and
that's sent up to v2 in other words that
moment in time is passed up to V 2 and V
2 pratt pot passes up all the way up to
the top of the hierarchy where you
recognize it and in for temporal cortex
right that's that actually is a pretty
good description of a Hubel and Wiesel
experiment right but but you know in the
real world there you don't get flashes
like that unless you're in a disco and
normally things are moving you know in
the in the background you move the
visual scene moves and as much in terms
of activity patterns and the cortex
they're much denser and we know that in
fact that changes the the level of
inhibition it produced so you get fewer
spikes out when you have several
suppression but now let's just think
about that okay from this perspective
suppose it was the case that as the
information is flowing in continuously
it's producing these ripples and waves
in the visual cortex in terms of
patterns of membrane potential
depolarization and hyperpolarization and
that they're interfering with each other
right what it means is that you've in
you've in a sense encoded like 100
milliseconds of time of movement and
activity in the visual field into into a
snapshot now if you took a picture of
that activity you would have information
not just about what's happening
now but what's happened in the near past
and what you're passing up the v2 isn't
just us no longer snapshot it's really a
movie it's information that that's been
encoded over a long you know significant
period of time it's really continuous a
continuous period so it's a history
that's moving up to the the top and so
at the top of the cortex is getting it's
much richer than a snapshot it's getting
encoded in space it's a much richer
representation of what's out there
right now yep so I just pointed out this
is what Wolfgang mas has been on about
with his act with his liquid state
machine it since the early two-thousands
and followed on with Herbert Jaeger yeah
yeah so so I think that this is that's a
good thing that you pointed this out in
in their case they had a randomly
connected network and but they did show
that the information can circulate
within a network right in the chaotic
way in fact a liquid state machine so so
in the metaphor they use this you know
you put you drop something in the pond
of stone in a pond and you get the
ripples and and and and what I guess
what I'm taking it one step further and
saying if you have a two-dimensional
sheet then it's really like a pond it
really is and and these these ripples
that are going out are spatially
coherent as well as temporally coherent
and and you know that this is the
beginning of a whole Luth potentially
whole new theory of vision which could
have something to do I mean and by the
way this is again reflecting if you go
back in the tradition Cuban weasel
tradition right there's no room in it
for oscillations in fact most of the
systems neuroscientist from that school
of vision dismiss oscillations out of
hand
I'm sorry clay you're you mean that
respond to what you believe but I could
tell you that all of my friends in
systems neuroscience they bought into
this rate code and they bought you know
the time is really irrelevant and by the
way they were they were inspired by the
fact that and Hubel and Wiesel show that
the spike timing didn't matter right it
was really the total number spikes that
was that was what was correlated with
the stimulus just buying in know if I
got to push back
little bit here I mean a workaday
electrophysiologist can correlate rates
to all kinds of things I'm not denying
that I'm just saying that if you only
look at one neuron out of time you're
never gonna see a traveling wave except
except it will introduce variability and
you're recording exactly the site or
depends on one that you will traveling
waves they're going through whether or
not you get any spikes you see I mean in
other words it's actually this may
explain a lot of the variability that
they see in fact there's something like
the colonia account for less than half
of the variance of the by the sensory
input of the actual signal and if we if
I showed you and John Reynolds
recordings you can account for like 80
or 90 percent of the variance if you
also know what the wave is doing I think
there's that there's a difference in the
point that you folks making you're
talking about sleep and the idea is to
communicate information that involves a
temporal sequence in sleep in the wake
state you would expect that there would
be local field potential variation but
it may not have the globally coherent
structure that you're singing these
waves in effect the awake state is the
online algorithm that somehow
transiently encoding I think is what
you're saying this structure so that
then during sleep it gets reinforced by
the interaction between the traveling
wave and the Rosati cycle or whatever
and that could be in different frequency
bands on different scales spatial scales
you know sleep go back to your pictures
that was during REM sleep
no that was stage 2 sleep which is
intermediate non REM sleep okay how
about wake did you do similar pictures
well I showed on Reynolds was a wake
behaving monkey and and there are the
travelling ways there are 10 Hertz which
is the same frequency band of spindles
but they're that spindles they're just
transient ways that are passing through
the cortex but you know I'm not trying
to say that the average finery doesn't
carry information it does it just
doesn't carry all of it they're there
and and and the importance of underst
intrinsic patterns of activity may be
telling us something about other
functions that the cortex has which has
to do with organizing the information
across the spatial extent communication
I gave an example of that in terms of
the sleep spindles so I mean I think
that we have to be broaden our idea of
what's going on in the cortex yeah
they're two different ways to think
about you know salutatory activity one
is that it gates information flow but
doesn't carry information itself and
then the other version is that the
oscillation itself is somehow encoding
the information and I took the ladder it
just doesn't seem like they're enough
bits in it to me right I mean it's like
you know I mean you should think ok ok
ok so ok so there's there's another ok I
think that we have been blinded by
spikes in other words these spikes are
so definite and so pretty that somehow
you know we really try to attribute all
the information to the spikes and of
course over a long distance that's true
but if you're looking at what's
happening locally there's a tremendous
amount of activity that's below the
level of the threshold and I show you
from a mirror and grimball's recordings
that that's got to be there and it's
affecting the spikes at some level it
carries information what do you mean
there's not enough information I mean
the sub-threshold probably has more
information
it's like you know a coherent traveling
wave I can just describe it by like oh
ok no no no you're thinking like a
physicist no
you know it takes a sinner to Nova
Center right but no so it turns out that
that's when there's a spot of light or
you drop a ball and that's the simplest
pattern because you know you can look at
it and see but what I'm saying is that
for a real scene and the real natural
world it's incredibly complex it's not
it's no longer a ripple or probably not
a regular traveling wave because there
are there could be interference between
different locations and it's going to be
a much more complex pattern and could
potentially carry a lot of information
by the way okay so that step that's true
in terms of how far it's spreading
within a layer so in terms of the long
range horizontals they're slow but
that's okay because they're only over a
few millimeters right but we know that
v1 does a lot of local processing so
that's not surprising but if as you go
up the hierarchy right you're getting
information like a you know from larger
and larger parts of the visual field so
that you're able to now reproduce these
waves now that are integrating
information from across the visual field
so no I think that you know you're
raising a really interesting constraint
that we have to put into the whole thing
yes did you try to a to decode this is
this travelling very structured and
empty only in so far as we've been able
to regress it against the hip hits and
misses right but you know there's this
is like you know it table combos is
actually that's it's distortions riding
on top of the travelling waves
information it's not that the structure
of the travelling wave itself so it's a
little bit different from the picture
that of your physicist friends
yeah look at the physics experiment is a
metaphor I'm sorry you know I don't take
it too seriously it's just that you know
there you can analyze it you come up
with a theory you can show that the
inverse problem can be solved okay well
that's it that's a challenge now you
know let's let's see if we can
generalize that right know that but
that's exactly the point there's that
there's a whole new set of questions
here that we need to be able to explore
that you know we just haven't even
considered before and you know and now I
want to end by just saying that part of
the problem I think we have is thinking
that there is only one neural code right
that can't be the case
nature is smarter than we are right and
and there's no reason why Nature
shouldn't actually employ several codes
for different conditions for when things
are changing quickly when things are
moving slowly when it's dark when you
have you know very few photons and we
know that the retina has an adaptation
over vast range of logs of intensity and
and and why shouldn't the cortex have
similar ways of adapting to different
classes of stimuli and and it's just
that you know we we were so myopic in a
sense that we latch on so the first
thing that is reproducible and you know
you run with it but the point at some
point you really have to start
broadening your possibilities and to
explore other things that now have been
observed for a long long time not
understood these oscillations but now
that we know they're all traveling waves
right it really opens up a whole new
spectrum here and just to finish up this
is Lyle Muller my postdoc here are my
collaborators and then like I said I've
had over twenty years of thinking about
sleep spindles and I had to say that
just this this recent work in humans it
wasn't discovered in animals right it
was the human brain that really taught
us something that we didn't know before
and so thank you for your attention
so I guess we just continue the
discussion maybe we just follow the flow
of the questions right now
and then we can transition in a more
general discussion and technically
basically at five o'clock also the the
buffet is outside and we can you say
there's a technical thing outside no no
no technically speaking at five pm I
think they'll starting so there will be
then though we're talking about liquid
refreshments yes okay